the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
okay so yeah problem set two there's a
lot of work done congratulations all the
workers sixteen trillion hashes
performed how can we prove that so this
is sort of a personal sort of gripe that
I hear a lot that people say that proof
of work doesn't scale and that really
bugs me
because I think I sometimes I just think
I sorta know what they're talking about
and I mean like you know Bitcoin doesn't
scale or like these block chains have
for scalability properties which sure
sure they definitely do but proof of
work it scales sort of perfectly in a
theoretical sense like there's nothing
that can scale better you can prove an
arbitrary amount of work in oh of one
right so in this case well how big were
these headers they were like less than
100 bytes right hundred characters and
with that space you can prove actually
the entire work that happened over the
entire problem set so yeah block chains
whole bunch of scalability problems
there's you know complex systems all
sorts of scaling issues but proof of
work itself in this pure form scales
really great okay so question not super
intuitive but how do you prove all the
work ever done throughout the entire
problem set in one line does anyone have
any intuition about the sort of how do
you prove all the work from all eighteen
thousand eight you know eighteen hundred
blocks with just one piece of data
okay yes so the thing is how do I prove
the number of blocks without showing all
of them right so I it's okay it's kind
of a weird trick question um Andrew I
don't think I remember Andrew Miller
who's now a professor at somewhere
Cornell who was not during the time sort
of wrote about this initially in the
Bitcoin forums what you do is you just
show the luckiest block and I've not yet
to find luckiest block but in this case
it's it was mined by turtle it's you
know this is the block or the previous
block reference was a hoe 65 a two
turtle one six five four two four four
and the hash of that block is zero zero
c49
a 4-1 for moi so anything interesting or
novel about this particular block that
you can see it's not but it's it's
better it's like there's more work so we
didn't count the things that's having
more or less work just by some number of
zeros we just looked at the threshold
did it have enough zero bits and accept
it or reject it
but in this case these four bytes right
you needed you needed four bytes and
then one extra bit right you need 233
bits so these four always were zero but
then and she and read there's another
extra byte that's all zeros and another
extra half a bite it's all zeros and
then a C means for that what you call it
nibble that the highest bit was one
right so you've got this red stuff
there's a bite and a half extra almost a
bite and a half extra so yeah so what
you can do for a compact proof of work
so if you look at this again there's you
know for for green bites
bite and a half that's red right so
that's five and a half bites so forty
four bits and two to the 44 is 17
trillion right if you do it out 17
something which is what we expect right
that's sort of our proof right we did 16
trillion hashes for our calculation and
and it shows up here and another way to
look at it is we needed 33 bits for a
valid block
we have 44 bits here that's 11 bits
extra that's 11 bits of like being lucky
and so that's 11 bits 2 to the 11 it's
2048 which is pretty close to the 1862
that we actually performed right so in
this case we're a little lucky we might
have only had to the 10 and then we
could only prove that we'd done like a
trillion work instead of sixteen
trillion work so so you know there's
there's probabilities here but this is
an interesting property that actually
does work you can prove all the work you
know to some across summation usually
within a factor of two that the system
has ever done just with one block header
so yeah this this is fun because another
way to look at it is that you've got
this sort of meta game where for every
block found how much how you know take
the I'm doing a hash and I need to find
a hash with a lot of zeros to prove that
I've done work and you sort of like
going level deeper and say okay I'm
finding a block and I want to prove that
I found an even better block than
everyone else right the the the entry
for admission here is find a valid block
and then from those blocks since it's a
you know just uniform distribution with
ones and zeros you're going to have this
tail end of like happen to have lots of
zeros that you didn't need in the
beginning and that can prove all the
work ever done there's a really
interesting paper called hyper log log
that uses this for non Bitcoin
applications that uses it for like set
counting we're sort of like on a website
you want to see how many unique visitors
you've gotten or something and you can
store that in row of one space because
you could keep track of like okay let me
keep track of every IP address that's
ever visited or something like that or
cookie but instead you sort of hash them
see if the hash starts with a bunch of
zeros or any arbitrary character and
then just store the lowest and then
every you know every time someone visits
hash it compare if it's lower replace if
not ignore and then you have a very
compact sort of indication of how many
visitors have visited anyway that's like
a super high-level view of it but if
you're interested in this kind of stuff
hyper log log as a paper builds off of
some other things it has nothing to do
with Vic
and other than this property where
you've got this like random function and
you see how many zeros are in it but I
don't I think these are kind of cool and
so it to me this is like a fun this is
not used in Bitcoin right in Bitcoin you
actually download all the headers but
people have sort of written papers about
how you could use it if long term the
headers are you know big you could you
know prove have some like checkpoint
we're like look I proved all the
previous work and now I build from there
any questions about this idea yes really
it's just a probability wait yes but the
proof of work itself is the same not of
Rila proof right because you might have
gotten lucky so so finding a block you
know it is they say it's sort of like
well that's not a proof there could be
luck involved there could be probability
but it's the exact same luck in
probability that the underlying proof of
work uses so there's no like further
reduction in security or certainty
because of this not really and so I
remember talking about this with someone
a few years ago and saying yeah proof of
work is it's sort of a misnomer it's not
really a proof right maybe it's an
argument of work or some kind of
probabilistic argument of work how could
you make it more certain as a proof
there's a bunch of ways one way would be
to have multiple nonces right where
instead of just finding one nuts that
satisfies it you have to find several
replaceable nonces and then like iterate
through them that would be a much more
certain proof it would remove the idea
of probability to some extent it would
also completely break the system in a
way that's like fairly unintuitive and
so I always sort of joking like I should
make an altcoin where you've got like
multiple nonces and you could be like
yes for more security and then people
would you know buy it but it completely
breaks the the completely broken
incentives and system maybe I'll hit me
I'll let you guys like think about it
till one thing and then you know draw it
out and be like why wouldn't this work
it's kind of fun it breaks in subtle but
bad ways
this is sort of talking about like proof
of work optimization so if you look at
this slide anyway
you've got these headers right or blocks
or whatever we're mining so you've got
KZ K 17 Tom Riddle finally to like all
these people mining it's interesting to
see what people use some people use like
looks like base64 some people just used
like a decimal number all sorts of
different things who knows there was
also a lot of invalid blocks with valid
work submitted where there was like four
or five different things they did my
spaces so this didn't count but actually
a lot more work was done and that's not
even counting the human work of doing
all the assignments so sending this over
the wire or storing it on disk some
inefficiencies may jump out at you what
it what uh what do you think you could
do to make this more efficient or
compress it or yeah okay that's an easy
one
oh this doesn't work when I gave you the
slides because you can just look at the
next slide and yeah oops okay nevermind
yeah so the first eight characters are
always gonna be zeros right like it by
definition if it's not it's an invalid
block so don't even bother sending it so
the first characters are zero don't send
them over the wire just have that
implied right I just start at the
whatever ninth character that saves well
really you'd have this serialized in
binary so it only saves four bytes in
this case in our case it would save
eight bytes that's cool and then also
the entire previous hash when you're
sending a list of five here like here in
order for it to be valid you know this
has to be the hash of the line above it
so just don't send the whole thing right
just send name nuts the hash is also
computable from anyone receiving it that
takes almost all of the space right and
we could we could sort of compress this
entire blockchain to just the first line
and that's the only that's the only full
line we need after that it's just named
nonce named nuts and we'd get rid of
like what seventy something percent of
the space that's pretty cool right yeah
this kind of header optimization is also
very much possible in Bitcoin and it's
not implemented it's not done if you
want to you could program you know
program it change Bitcoin have this like
make a pull request I think I mean we
discussed it and people are like yeah
that'd be cool but mm-hmm no one's done
it so if you want to like leave your
mark and be like I'm a Bitcoin core
contributor and I optimized the
proof-of-work propagation system or
something sounds cool
you could do this it's not too hard you
got to learn how Bitcoin works and all
they're like you know different messages
and stuff so it's a little annoying I
think the main reason people haven't
done it is because it's this is not the
slow part right this is not the critical
path not a bottleneck in the actual
system generally the the proof of work
verification is pretty quick the headers
are total of like 40 something megabytes
now 50 megabytes maybe so you could you
could definitely reduce that by a
significant extent but no one's bothered
because there's so many other scaling
issues that are more pressing but it's
kind of cool I think someone might so
yeah that'd be a fine fun thing to do if
you did that right would that be a soft
or hard fork if you said okay I'm going
to now send header messages that are
truncated all right I'm gonna leave off
the four bytes that are always zeroes
the coin is also the four you know the
difficulty requirement here is basically
the same as difficulty as in Bitcoin I'm
going to you know have the implied
previous block hash things like that
would that be a fork actually it
wouldn't right it's sort of a non fork
there are lots of changes you can make
so I known a-ha talked about you know
soft works and hard Forks you know
changes you can make in the system that
affect consensus but there's a lot of
changes you can make that optimize it
but don't really affect other people so
in this case it would just sort of be a
wire protocol change and you could
easily maintain backwards compatibility
right so in this case you say the header
optimization it's not a fork right what
you do is you'd have a new message type
like truncated header or something and
then when you connect to nodes you say
hey do you know about this new message
type I'm using and if they don't know
you're talking about or they usually
they say what version they are when do
they connect and you're like oh you're
an old version you don't know about this
I'll just keep saying the old header
type and even if I store the new
truncated headers on disk I can recreate
the old one pretty quickly
right by stacking them you know
performing the hash tacking down on
Sunday
you so I can have it I can be compatible
back backwards compatible and forwards
compatible no soft works needed the old
nodes they don't even see that this
happens they might see that there's oh
there's a new version or a new message
I'm not aware of they ignore it
everything seems fine
so these are kind of the easiest they're
not forced the easiest changes in the
system get through because there's no
real coordination needed and it's
backwards and forwards compatible so
that's cool
so some example non Forks a lot of them
are internal only that don't even you
can't even see from outside so for
example compressing blocks or compress
it you know compressing your database
that's fairly straightforward right it
doesn't seem like intuitively it seems
like well these are all like random
numbers and hashes you can't really
compress those right because they're
random in practice you actually can
people reuse public keys a lot and so
you just see the same pub key over and
over so you do some pretty simple
encoding and you can make those smaller
also the amounts is 8 bytes so if you're
sending someone you know one Bitcoin
that's you know 100 million and people
like to use round numbers and so those
get compressed pretty well and generally
there's you know much smaller so the top
bytes are usually zeros so you can
compress it a decent amount but no one
has to know that you're compressing
right that's all transparent when
someone connects to you they have no
idea if you're compressing or not on
disk something like faster signature
verification where there's been enormous
amounts of work in optimizing the code
for that making assembly stuff like that
nobody knows you're doing it right
they're just like oh he's asking for
blocks quicker than this other person
maybe his networks faster maybe a CPU is
faster so these kind of are changes that
are purely internal nobody needs to know
that's kind of cool other non Forks are
peer to peer non Forks so the the
truncated headers maybe where you can
say hey I'm gonna send you less data
over the network you identify at connect
time and you default to the old behavior
people don't know what you're talking
about so there's one called compact
blocks
I didn't describe it but you can
probably guess what the idea of compact
blocks is anyone want to venture guess
what those do
Wow so it's not a header that's comeback
but the whole block
how would you compact a block actually
that would work that's not with you
there's a really big there's a really
big like 2x redundancy send so the basic
idea is transactions are propagated and
then the blocks propagated whereas the
redundancy there yeah the transactions
the block you probably already seen them
right you see the transactions and the
block comes out most of it in general 90
something for cents like yeah I already
see all this so compact blocks is a way
to in you know say hey here is the block
here were all the transactions in it but
I don't show the whole transaction I
just so like the TX ID the hashes and
then you can say okay 90% of those I've
already seen so we're good
here's these 50 transactions I have not
seen please give them to me so it's
interacted rights like here the here's
the blocks with just the UH transaction
identifiers okay what do you need
okay I need these ten okay here's the 10
and now I can reconstruct the whole
block so the block goes from being like
a megabyte over the wire to something
like 10 kilobytes but it's but it is a
little slower in that it's like a multi
round thing right it's like here's the
compact block okay I need these extra
things okay here's the exercise so a
little bit more complexity if you're
really optimizing for latency then you
don't want to use this but in general
it's a pretty big gain in terms of
bandwidth which can be taxing on full
notes
I run a full there's a full node on the
first floor in one little rack and it it
uploads three terabytes a month or so
depends on how much people are using
Bitcoin like in December everyone starts
downloading it and installing it and
there's a lot of bandwidth needed to
like sync people up another non Fork was
the bloom filters which no full nodes
can then say hey I will perform bloom
filter calculations for you and light
nodes can connect in like I said too
go with SPV light notes can submit a
bloom filter say hey when I download a
block from you first filter the block
you know match all the transactions
against this bloom filter and only send
me things that match that's not a fork
but it's a fairly fairly involved you
know change in the peer-to-peer code
okay any questions about these
peer-to-peer non Forks good cool there's
another aspect called standard miss
where you haven't soft Forks something
out you haven't declared something
invalid but you can declare it
non-standard and what that means is when
your node sees a transaction right
coming over unconfirmed a transaction
being propagated through the network and
it's got this property you say oh that's
non-standard I'm gonna drop it I'm going
to ignore it I won't propagate it on to
my peers I won't ban I don't it depends
I don't know do i ban the person
submitting it to me I think you don't
but I ignore it I don't propagate it so
it doesn't really get around the network
when most of the peers on the network
have these rules of non-standard miss
it's gonna be very difficult to get your
transaction out there however if you see
this non-standard transaction in a block
you accept the block you say okay well
that was this weird thing that I didn't
like but since it's in a block and
someone did a lot of work on it I will
accept it and it's a little weird right
like why have this it's sort of
something that's not quite a software
right it's showing that we're
discouraging this we think it's
non-standard the miners software by
default we'll also consider this
non-standard and not mine it but if
someone else is mining it we're okay
with it and so what you can do is you
can stage future soft Forks this way
right so for example in in segue oh I
didn't talk about the segment at all I'm
gonna have to do that next week okay so
in segue so the segment was like the
biggest sophomore ever in Bitcoin and it
occurred last year it changed the output
scripts to say just like
it changed the output scripts so before
you said you know op do op hash 160 the
hash op checks off equal whatever here
it just says zero just pushes a zero
byte and then pump key hash and that's
it and if you actually interpret that in
the stack no signature is needed right
you push a zero to the bottom of the
sack you push a pump key on the top of
that and then your execution halts and
you're like well there's a non zero
piece of data on the top I interpret non
zero data as true right the same way she
does so it's true you don't need a
signature at all so that's sort of the
weird Segway soft work where they said
no what used to be considered true
without a signature we now sort of
template and we say this means pump you
know check funky ash right this means
the same as op do pop hash 160 hash op
equals objects except sake right so what
you actually do is you know you need to
provide the pub key that this hashes
into and then check a signature it also
defined 1 2 3 up to 16 and left this
undefined and said look these are now
non-standard before if you I think but
you know the idea is if you just push a
1 on the stack and then push some data
well I guess no signatures needed but
now they're non-standard because it
means we're gonna use these next the
next soft work the next soft work will
define what one some piece of data means
maybe it's a new signature scheme maybe
it's a new kind of program where you put
some data here but it's non-standard so
if you try to make a transaction that's
using like two and then a data push all
the nodes will be like yeah I'm not
ready for that like I haven't I haven't
seen that and if you see I think in your
air logs if you see a block with a bunch
of these kinds of things it'll give you
a warning
it's like warning people are using stuff
that your software doesn't know about
you might need to upgrade there's a
bunch of warnings like that we're like
warning like the last you know some
percentage of the last few blocks had
these things so people are doing stuff
that you're not considering invalid
right you're not gonna like refuse the
block but you're also like this is
something I don't understand right and
I've specifically coded it as
non-standard okay so any questions about
non-standard miss neha talked about soft
forks and hard forks right and I will go
through a bit more detail about sort of
how these end up working and how these
interact with minors and notes did
people have questions about soft forks
and hard forks before we start like sort
of got the general idea right soft works
add new rules hard forks remove rules in
general and this is minors okay so the
minors have sort of a unique role here
it's not just the same as a full node a
minor you know decides what to put into
a block that they're mining and so they
do have a bit more influence in these
fork decisions okay so soft Fork would
be for example saying okay all output
amounts must be odd right
you can't send an even number of coins
to anyone anymore that would be a weird
silly fork wouldn't really impact the
usability of the system but it'd be kind
of dumb but you could do it and you
could say okay well if I see a block if
I see a transaction which outputs if any
of the outputs have an even number of
Satoshi's invalid you got to do odd
potentially leading to the loss of one
Satoshi per transaction fees one Satoshi
per block may end up being lost due to
this so so here I'm saying an A for
adopter and I for ignorer now people may
ignore the fork because they disagree
with it they don't want to do this fork
or they may do it because you know they
may just not even know that this
software exists it's a you know giant
decentralized system and it's hard to
know how to communicate with everyone
right there isn't there so there is like
you know Bitcoin dot-org there's also
Bitcoin comm where the guy doesn't like
the Bitcoin developers and says they're
bad you know anyone can just register
these things there's a Bitcoin Twitter
account
that was purchased recently by someone
who wanted to argue about these things
so like you know there's no one really
in charge of this and then there's also
like different implementations there's
the real Bitcoin which is run by this
bunch of crazy people who say they
control Bitcoin and then everyone has to
pay them taxes and bitcoins in there
yeah but they're all running Bitcoin
right they all are in consensus and
doing these transactions so ignoring
could be any number of things if you
have a soft fork where you say okay
we're now adding this rule but none of
the miners are enforcing it none of the
miners even know about it potentially
here it just stops right you say no I
require that all output amounts are odd
and then every block has these even
amounts and you're like okay no that's
not a valid block that's not a valid
block you will never see a valid block
again right none of the miners are
enforcing this rule but you are
everyone's ignoring it and they say you
know everyone's ignoring it everything
seems fine
you just self you know you just
self-imposed this new rule making you
incompatible with the rest of the
network and from your perspective
everything stops and no more blocks
occur and the system is over or
potentially if you're if you're
sophomoric is some like weird rule that
nobody knows about and nobody breaks
anyway weak say okay the some of the
outputs of all you know the some of the
outputs in a transaction must not be a
Carmichael number okay
you could have that rule probably no
one's breaking wait there's a lot of
small company something like that right
where no one's breaking it anyway then
from your perspective everything's cool
because everyone's already of a your
rule because even though they don't know
about it it's kind of silly another
possibility is let's say I'm minority
somewhere 1 to 50% of the miners adopt
this rule and say yeah we're gonna
enforce this new role right all output a
Massa need to be awed so the idea is you
say yes only odd numbers and a bunch of
the majority actually of people don't
care about odd or even so the majority
they still go off on their own chain but
you split off into your own faction you
say like no we're the odd you know the
odd bunch and both of the
chains are viable blocks come out here
maybe quite slowly if it's only a few
percent blocks they'll come out here the
fact so you've got these you know odd
thing you know odd and then you've got
regular and the regular is gonna be
longer right the regular is gonna be
potentially a lot longer but from the
people here they're like we don't care
if it's longer it's wrong we you know
they use even numbers that's just plain
old wrong and these people are like yeah
we can sometimes see it but actually we
lose track of it very quickly after here
we start seeing block advertisements
like this and we're like what we're over
here now we're way past that why are you
talking about this stuff from like weeks
ago so they just disconnect it's pretty
ugly but that can happen now if you have
the majority of the hash power this ends
up being longer the odd blocks end up
being longer and everyone gets dragged
along right no split and now we have a
new rule right even though they didn't
know about the rule potentially so
they're like what the heck
half my transactions don't work some of
them do so I don't know what's going on
I just randomly adjust my fees until it
seems to work and then my transactions
go through they should probably find out
from someone oh yeah there's the new
rule only odd numbers and then they you
know that rules have imposed on them
from the miners essentially in the rest
of the network and essentially the same
thing here when you get to 100% there's
no there's none of these orphans but it
works re these orphans would actually be
like this right because everyone's
everyone agrees that this is valid and
then some of the people's aren't aware
of the rule and keep mining off of these
what they consider valid blocks
it's a little different topology okay so
that makes sense right any questions
about soft fork mining power rules one
other aspect is if you split here and
then later on you get a majority and you
pull ahead you will reorg
the ignoring side right so we split off
with ten
the hash power we've got our short or
much shorter chain where we only have
odd numbers at some point we convince
the rest of the miners that no this is
the way to go
that even numbers are really screwing up
this system and we get the majority of
the hash power and then we overtake the
even and odd mix chain the people who
have not yet who have not updated their
software and are ignoring the fork they
will reorg app because from their
perspective okay I was on the longer
chain now there's this other longer
chain they both look valid and when I
see two valid chains my way to decide is
who has the most work and so I know this
one pulled ahead in terms of work so I
switched so it's it's a weird this has
never really happened that I'm aware of
they were threatening to do it last
summer they had hats
I said you ASF I don't know so yeah
there was all sorts of stuff on the
internet and Reddit and Twitter about
doing this with a minority of hash power
they didn't though or they did and they
say they did but everyone else is they
didn't matter a lot of arguing okay so
that's another weird aspect of it ok
hard Forks no minor support what happens
to those adopting it nothing right
everything keeps working if you say ok
we're now going to allow every
transaction output you know every
transaction can have one extra Satoshi
gets created it's just one it's no big
deal it's quite limited but we want to
you know compensate people for using
bitcoins so when you have it you know
you have your inputs you have your
outputs you can add one Satoshi and you
get a free Satoshi for a transaction the
previous software absolutely does not
allow that right if you're just
generating money out of nowhere and
these transactions not ok but these guys
will say you know they'll see that the
transactions they do that with are not
confirming but otherwise they're ok if
you don't add a Satoshi and so the
system works
nothing happens nothing happens they
just see everything with a minority of
the hash power something like 10 20 %
you get all these orphans get all these
dead ends where you you see a block
okay and it's got this you know at once
Satoshi four transaction bonus great but
it keeps getting more fanned out because
you still consider alright so you see
okay here's this longest chain without
the bonus and then you say oh here's
here's a block with the bonus cool maybe
someone builds too great but this keeps
getting longer and you keep trying but
you keep getting overpowered right
because you see both of them as valid
you're not requiring that there's this
one Satoshi bonus per transaction you're
just allowing it
and so you see oh this is cool cool oh
no not really so you see all these
little starts that get reordan out and
you basically stay with the same chain
you don't split these people also see a
bunch of invalid blocks right you'll see
it on the network a someone keeps
sending these invalid blocks much more
frequently than usually I don't know why
they're doing that but they've got
invalid transactions I ignore them here
majority of hash power you split right
so once it's the majority and these are
the you know the bonus the plus ones
they pull out ahead these guys don't
actually care that they have a majority
after the first block they don't see the
rest of they band so if someone submits
you an invalid block you ban them you've
been their IP address for like 24 hours
or something you're like I don't know
what you're doing you're crazy
disconnect so you won't really see this
pretty quickly these guys don't have the
bonus they're still on their same old
blockchain it may be much slower right
because how a lot of the hash power is
now moved to this other chain and these
guys say oh it worked
cool we've got our new you know bonus
coin chain and now we're you know
stimulating the economy everything like
that job creation okay so and then these
guys you know slower slows down and then
if you have a hundred percent
well stops for the non-adopters no more
blocks come out this is the end
everyone's gone to the you know job
creations train and look you know it's
not really a split anymore it's just you
know the new rule
okay so any questions there this sort of
grid so far then another way you can do
it is combine these to say okay we're
gonna do a sophomore and a hard fork at
the same time and actually many times
that people say hard fork they actually
mean this so the nomenclature is pretty
ambiguous I like keeping these terms
very distinct and like you know pure so
like a sophomore is purely increasing
the number of rules where you know must
be odd and a hard Fork is just reducing
rules so like yes we will allow but not
require a transaction to have this
property and then to combine them would
be something like saying we allow this
new thing that was not allowed before
and we require it to be true so for
example every transaction must introduce
one new satoshi bonus that would be both
a hard and a soft work right because now
this you know if you're doing this you
no longer consider the old rules
appropriate and you you know there's a
complete mutual disagreement on the
rules some people have called this full
fork who called it that I forget Gregg
called it a bilateral hard fork I we
don't have good terms for these things a
lot of people refer to Forks that have
both as hard Forks so it's somewhat
ambiguous I think it helps to keep these
different terms but it's a different set
up it's sort of the union of these two
things in some way in that we enforce
you know we allow this new thing that
was prohibited before and not only that
but we require it so if zero percent
enforced the new hard fork well the
adopters it just stops right there
requiring this new thing it's not
showing up it ends these guys nothing
happens right when there's a minority it
will split off it'll split off with the
new rule set in the new you know bonus
coins or whatever and the ignores they
see that it's you know slower because
some people have left some mining powers
left when you have a majority you also
split off and
ignores again it's slow they're not
going to adopt because it's they see the
the new Fork is invalid in this case as
well they will you know these guys won't
adopt here because they see it as valid
and then for the full thing you know for
the hundred-percent the adopters new
rule and these guys system halts okay so
any questions about full fork or
bilateral fork we're never you want to
call it okay okay cool
[Music]
yes bilateral hard full we don't know
them good names for these but yeah they
you know it's essentially a software and
a hard for couple together and it's
actually sort of this is much simpler or
easier to produce and then if you just
start changing the code you're probably
gonna create one of these right you have
to be very careful if I want I want just
a hard fork right I'm I'm very careful
at all everything that used to be valid
is still valid and I'm just rescinding
one rule or one set of rules if you just
you know it's very easy to inadvertently
create this when you're trying to make
consensus changes yeah there have been
Nick I should look Nate huh didn't they
I talked about the 2013 fork I don't
think so okay so a little anecdote
remember I was in the airport I got to
Nagoya Airport and open my laptop and
basically I went down to like $20 from
$30 and it was like all over the
internet like oh no and there was a
inadvertent heart Fork due to the
berkeley DB to leveldb transition in the
software no no it was it was old the 0.7
was using burke it used to be everything
was using berkeley DB for the UT Exocet
in the blocks and then they switch to
level DB and then like it was okay for a
month or two and then someone mind like
a block that was like had a bunch of
inputs or something I don't remember
exactly the reasons and
like the new software was like yeah
that's cool and the old software said it
wasn't okay the thing is it wasn't clear
why right it's it there was no defined
like this should be invalid like this
looks valid but the database the
Berkeley DB layer gave an error and so
it's like well Burt the database says
it's bad so it's not a good block so
that was sort of a weird like
unintentional consensus change what
happened was so it seemed like it was a
hard fork the thing is it was like a
compiler time option dependent hard fork
like he compiled it with like a
different berkeley DB cache setting then
it would work it was like not you know
sort of ambiguous and people rolled back
though they were on IRC and they talking
to their friend miners they're like
what's going on there's like two
different Forks being built and they
told the people who were up you know to
some extent in the right right like the
new version which seemed more correct to
stop mining and they did and then the
old version with the berkeley DB cap
caught up and then they sort of
restricted their block size it was
something to do with like having too
many file locks open or something like
that so that was one of it was
essentially a hard fork they sort of
stopped it and then went back so there
wasn't a hard fork but then like months
later they're like okay we're gonna all
transition the level D because we're not
even sure what the rules are
yeah and the thing is they definitely
did like at the time people are sort of
running around screaming like y-you know
like after the fact they're like that's
why but at the time people are sort of
like talking really quick and like
what's going on Bitcoin has failed sell
all your bitcoins like this system
doesn't work because no one really knew
what was going on or why some you know
some versions weren't working so yeah
that was sort of an unintended fork it
was a little scary and then and then the
price went back up after that because it
was like hey we can we can work through
this guy so that was that was a hard
that was a hard work right the old
software would not allow these blocks
that opened a bunch of file locks and
the new software did and and so that was
probably the one real hard fork that
Bitcoin has been through there were a
few maybe in 2009 that like are fairly
ambiguous because there were no there
was no actual split I think there's also
a hard fork that's happened but it
didn't it's a little weird it has to do
with the timestamp in the block header
and how it like expires in 2106 once you
run out of bits from unix time like 1970
plus two to the 32 seconds is like 2106
and january silviana and so they
actually did a hard fork but the thing
is the hard fork wouldn't diverge until
100 years from now so it's sort of like
whatever everyone will live updated by
then if someone's still running software
from 2015 in 2106 they will diverge but
that seems unlikely
so there's a lot of weird stuff like
that okay ah fun variants some people
call it firm fork people call it evil
fork I'm I think Peter - I'll call it
evil or firm I don't know but I don't
know this is a fun one it has not been
attempted and and it's I remember
talking to people and they're like don't
talk about this
the miners don't know they can do this
so just I'm like come on like they don't
know they could do this it's kind of
like okay so how would you do this make
a soft 4
it's a hard fork right it completely
changes the rules however it looks like
a soft fork to non adopting notes it's
kind of gravy well the proof of work for
the new chain is a empty but valid block
on the old chain so you instead of your
proof of work being hey have a header
that hashes to this say have a header to
the hash to this also a block that is
valid but completely empty we'll sort of
take that as our header right or header
now gets bigger instead of 80 bytes is
gonna be 200 something bytes but that's
doable now our header chain is a chain
of empty blocks and our actual blocks
point to that right we can put our
merkel root in the output address or
something we can put our merkel root
somewhere in this empty block
transaction you know the one transaction
in the block the old nodes will see it
and say yeah that's a trent you know
that's a block someone's mining where
here's where the money went but there's
no transactions in it my transactions
never confirm you don't actually have to
connect to the old network to do this
right it's totally deterministic you
just say ok my new proof of work is a
valid but empty block on the old one
and I commit somewhere in this to my new
block that's kind of evil because what
happens is here's the chart for this
it's basically a firm 4 Plus this little
evil thing the adopting if you have no
hash bar wealth system halts and nothing
changes here if you have one to 50
percent the adopting split off with a
new rule so in this case it's sort of
like a hard board however the main
difference from hard fork if you have a
majority hash power the ignoring the
system essentially halts it doesn't halt
in that the blocks keep coming out right
you'll still see your software won't
give you any warnings it must be like a
block height keeps progressing as normal
as expected we keep sailing all these
blocks however no transactions occur and
you can never receive or send money but
according to your software everything's
working fine so this is the sort of firm
evil sneaky whatever part where if
you're able to get 51% of the mining and
you implement the
new fork you're basically forcing
everyone to update because if you don't
if you don't update your software if
you're ignoring the spork can't do
anything you got a you got a new rule
this is scary and I can see why some
people like don't tell minors they can
do this also I remember last year with
like segue to X stuff I think they were
arguing about this and it really seemed
that they were not aware of this
possibility which was sort of like huh
they don't know about this cool I guess
that helps keep things safer because
they were arguing about how they were
going to rent like hundreds of millions
of dollars of hash power to like mine
empty blocks on the old chain it's like
you know you can do that for free if you
just change your software to make your
new proof-of-work an empty block on the
old proof of work but I don't think they
were aware of that so we're like okay
let them let them go with that anyway
and so the thing is it you can see how
it would really quickly turn into that
right if you've got 75% well why would
anyone try to mine on this you know you
could keep making blocks that did
contains transactions but they'll get
orphaned out and everyone would would uh
you know you might occasionally see hey
a block came out with transactions in it
huh just got reaaargh out and nothing
would ever confirm so you can see how
the miners can never really get paid on
the minority fork and minority chain so
they're all gonna start switching to the
new thing if they want to get paid so
that's a little ugly this has not
happened yeah hopefully this doesn't
happen but I on the other hand despite
it being called evil I know like Luke
jr. was kind of crazy but he's cool he
was saying this is how we should do a
hard fork right we should also give
people the option to you know say look
there's going to be a fork we give you
the option to adopt a different system
or doing this so that no one's
inadvertently left behind so we sort of
say hey a year from now this is going to
happen you can either say we actively
refuse this new rule and we've got our
own chain now you know we make a soft
work before that point or we adopt this
new rule update our software and now
I've got this new
work the thing is the new proof of work
you don't need new chips right you just
need to like do a little bit different
software ok any questions about evil
forks well one transaction so you'd have
the coinbase transaction but any
user-created transactions would not be
in there and yeah in the case where
there's only one transaction the merkel
route just becomes the TX ID of that
single transaction and you can put
arbitrary data in that single
transaction the input field yeah we said
the input field for that that coinbase
transaction that generates new coins can
be any arbitrary data you want so you
could put like a merkel route from your
real block in there and then write your
new software to say ok the new
proof-of-work is you know not you know
the header with the nuns also it's got
to have a you know coinbase transaction
and then the real merkel root in the
coinbase transaction and then build out
your tree from there so it's a little
ugly it's a little more complex it would
totally work though and you know all the
old software would just be like huh no
transactions and all the new software
knows that that's not a real coinbase
transaction it's just a part of the new
you know the part of the extended header
ok cool
I you know don't try well I mean try
this at home if you want I don't know
yeah seems coercive that's evil people
call it ok yeah for coordination how do
you sort of go a level up from this how
do we know to do all these things
reddit IRC Twitter there's sort of you
know these systems exist on the real
world and people talk you know like the
meeting I was at last week we we
actually didn't talk about Forks much we
sort of did but you know the developers
get together companies using Bitcoin all
sorts of stuff ya know on Wednesday
people were arguing about mass versus
snorin which is more important which we
should try to soft work in first not
much gets done so it used to be called
bit 9 that's still there
between improvement protocol nine it was
the idea in the header in the header
field in the version field you can sort
of set these flag bits for which
Softworks you are adopting right so you
you indicate before adopting a fork
which one you're ready to adopt and then
you don't actually implement the
adoption until you see some threshold to
say okay once 95 percent of people are
signaling that we have this new
operation we'll all enforce it because
quite likely the software people don't
want this a lot of times you say look I
want this new rule I want this new
signature system or I want this new you
know even odd thing it'd be really bad
better if everyone only used odd numbers
however I'm not willing to split off
because of this right I want everyone I
want everyone on board or at least the
majority on board so we don't have a new
split we get the new rule this is what I
want well I like the rule but I'm not
willing to you know put a stake in the
ground and say look I'm making my own
network if you don't adopt it so in
order to do that we say we want to get a
majority of mining power to adopt it
before we start doing it and so that way
we can signal in the header that like
hey I'm aware of this new rule and I
will enforce it if everyone else says
they're going to enforce it so sort of a
staging process so that was called bit 9
and the idea is you know once 95% are
signaling it then you activate it
this didn't actually work in practice I
think it worked once with the OP check
sequence verify and then last year
people just arguing and the miners were
like no we're not going to activate any
new Softworks or then they started
making all these deals it it was a mess
governance yeah okay so yeah so the
future of software is definitely unclear
this is very much in flux how is this
gonna work in the future how are people
going to agree on these things right it
seems a lot of the times from the
developer perspective it seems like why
not like hey we made this cool new
signature system it's faster it's more
secure save space let's use it and then
people say no you're like well why
things like that but then on the other
hand if it's like no we only have odd
outputs
who cares let's use even in on Dahmer's
okay so another aspect with force
transaction replay so this is tricky so
a split happens let's say in the case of
a minority soft fork or a majority but
not unanimous hard fork or full fork
something like that there's a split
right there's two chains that are now
being extended you make a transaction on
the old chain what happens on the new
chain I mean yes yeah sign it and it
happens on both right all in many cases
these transactions are valid on either
and so they can be rebroadcast or
relayed between the two networks and if
it can be relayed between the two
networks it will someone's gonna
someone's gonna set up a little script
that grabs all the transactions on one
chain broadcast them on the other even
if you don't want them to like someone
will do that right and if it's valid on
both it gets confirmed on both and so
you say okay it now splits there's no
two different histories you know at the
time of the split now I've got coins on
both right
I don't usually think of it when it's a
short-term split as I now have two types
of coins but I do
if these extend indefinitely and they're
never gonna reconverge well I've still
got the UT exo's on both I can make a
transaction here and maybe it gets
relayed here and now they like move on
both sides or maybe it doesn't so you
can you can potentially and eventually
the UT x offsets will diverge right how
do you diverge these things well if you
mix it with coins that have been mined
right so you know that the mind they
know the new coin base the new coins
here are definitely different right
those are gonna have different TX ids
coins that got mined here will not exist
on this one and vice versa so eventually
more and more coins start getting mixed
in with each other and they will diverge
that takes a while though another thing
you can draw try to doing is just
spamming double spins I'm gonna send to
this injury I make a transaction you
know Alice pays Bob I also make a
transaction Alice pays Carol I just spam
won't you know send one to one place one
to the other hope they get in
eventually they'll start diverging right
just by chance you can also try
exploiting lock time Delta's so in many
cases the heights will be different and
you can say okay I'm here I'm gonna make
a transaction that's only valid after
block five and if someone replays it
here they're gonna have to wait two
blocks before it's valid and then this
gets confirmed here and then I make a
different transaction spending the coins
here without a time lock and so I can
try it I sort of exploit the fact that
there's timing differences between the
two chains to make you know transaction
a occur on the top one and transaction B
occur in the top on the bottom one and
split my coins off that way so those are
potential ways to split your coins
despite these transaction replays and
then you can now say okay have two
separate wallets two separate keys on
the different coin different chains
however yes this is expensive this is
ugly it's possible but it's ugly right
because you're basically gonna spam the
network and you know you in many cases
you're not actually trying to send money
you're just sort of moving your own
money around internally so if everyone
does that in the system it can overload
the system have tons of transactions
also if you're doing this it might not
work and you're like okay I just confirm
a transaction for no point whatsoever
got to keep trying it's pretty ugly also
people don't know right so why are these
why is this a problem well in many cases
you want to sell one and not the other
in addition to these software rules such
as you know bonus coins for each
transaction or only odd numbers allowed
there are often sort of philosophical
and cultural rules that get associated
with it and people hate each other and
yell at each other and insult each other
on the internet all the time this is I
don't think this is unique to Bitcoin or
crypto currencies I think it's just sort
of you know you got money involved you
got trolls on the internet it's a rich
mixture of you know the best parts of
humanity and so a lot of times people
want to sell one or the other right so
they say I think the odd coin is stupid
I'm gonna sell it and I want it you know
someone wants to buy it and I'll get
these new coins that's
difficult if transaction replays er
occurred another problem is that many
users could be unaware of the forks I
know a lot of people there have been you
know a bunch of sort of full Forks in
Bitcoin recently where rule you know
different rule sets have been adopted in
many cases entirely different proofs of
works things like that I'm not aware of
all of them I know of some of them I
most people I know don't know of all of
them or even all any of them so users
might unknowingly send both or not be
aware of these things that's the
National that's an issue there's also
all sorts of crazy legal issues talking
to exchanges we're like okay this Fork
happens do we owe our customers both do
we only owe them the one that you know
and and which you know does the exchange
have to let people decide to adopt or
ignore a new rule set there's all sorts
of weird legal issues that are still
being you know settled and for one
example here's what you can do a replay
attack on exchange and this is not a
theoretical example this has happened so
let's say the network splits right you
get bonus coin and regular old coin and
you know the bonus coin has a majority
hash rate and there's no kind of replay
protection right any all the
transactions that are valid and won or
valid on the other okay so the network
splits into coin and coin bait and the
exchange is only running coin B they say
look this has the most hash power and
that's what defines the system we don't
you know they adopted a new rule fine
there's this new rule that you can
generate a coin of nothing so the user
says to the exchange okay I'm gonna
deposit coin be the exchange says yes I
acknowledge your deposit of coin B
that's the network I'm running on I see
your transaction it's in a block cool
you've now got a balance and the user
says that you know changed my mind I'm
withdrawing coin D and the exchange so
what happens next exchange says sure
here's coin B oh and coin a right the
exchange doesn't implement any replay
protection they don't know they don't
acknowledge the existence of this other
chain it
no they have point a I mean they should
because they split you know they
actively split but whatever and then the
user is like cool I ever I got both
right I relayed this transaction between
the two networks I was now able to
deposit only claim B and withdraw both
coin a and point B and now I redeposit
you know I split again I redeposit coin
B and I keep doing that and so I can
drain the exchange of all of their coin
a with the same amount of coin B just
looping through depositing and
withdrawing so yeah this happens
does anyone I mean I'm not gonna say
which exchange was susceptible to this
attack does anyone know it shares a name
with the first transaction in the block
anyway I say yeah there was almost two
years ago like year and a half ago with
the etherium if you're in classic kind
of a hard fork that happened so that was
you know it happened I'm not saying yeah
it's not obvious right these are some
attacks that are like huh in retrospect
it wasn't that hard to find out like you
know I'm sure the people at the exchange
are like huh shoot yeah we probably
should have seen that coming and we lost
a couple million bucks shoot it's also
weird because like all of their users
like generally are identified and they
have like you know they're passed
forward or where they live and so you
could probably tell like hey come on
dude give it back thank you just but
it's maybe they didn't because they're
like well tech because because they
might have programmed in a way where
they could sort of deny it say like look
I just deposited and withdrew a couple
times that's what I always do I don't
know but yeah there were definitely
warnings there were there were a lot of
people saying like hey this is dangerous
you need to really implement replay
protection if you if there is a fork
without replay protection implemented
the exchanges really need to honor and
and try to split both before offering
both for deposit and withdrawal things
like that and so there's been a lot of
last year as well there's a lot of
argument because in Bitcoin one group of
people
- seg wit 2x was what it was called and
they wanted to implement a hard fork and
not implement replay protection and so
that was a big argument where people are
saying look if you're gonna make a hard
fork make it a full fork you know make
it implement so that you're you're gonna
go off but also implement replay
protection make it so that transactions
that you guys sign are slightly
different than the old way and it's not
too hard to do what you can do is sort
of when you're making a signature flip
some bits
well UK you can't flip bits in the
signature itself right because those can
be flipped back but what you can do is
you can like flip a bit or two in the
hash that you're signing and then the
old software won't be aware of that flip
and say look this doesn't look like
invalid signature because it's trying to
compare it against a different message
or you can like append something at the
end of the message you're signing things
like that so that on the new network the
signatures look different and that
that's that helps in terms of safety
because then like the old you know the
old software that's ignoring will not
inadvertently send transactions and also
for the new network they will not
inadvertently send transactions on the
old network so that's and there's a lot
of like the ideas of like opt-in versus
opt-out reclaim protection where you can
like allow the option to sign
differently but not require it all sorts
of weird ways you can do it but yeah
this is a fairly recent mostly life last
summer last fall people were like trying
to do different things and so in
practice I think that's the end of the
let me let me go like two more minutes
but yeah consensus changes are hard in
practice there's been some some full
Forks recently the last soft fork was
was segregated witness saying what
happened sometime in September or last
year like her act it was it was a mess
and there was also some full Forks
Bitcoin cash and then later Bitcoin gold
which is a lot smaller and they
completely changed the proof work and
now they're sort of a bunch that are
like pushing the definition of for a
full fork where they're basically like
also called airdrops
where it's sort of a completely
different coin that just happens to have
the you TXO side of the old point
and so it's like why even bother with
the history we're just like look it's a
new coin that happened you know you
inherit all these other coins
yeah I didn't anyway so there's a bunch
of those it's if it's a mess it's kind
of fun being you know I could not have
given this lecture a year ago a lot of
these things had not happened a lot of
these terms were not well-defined
a few years ago the idea of soft hard
forks were not even defined like it's
pretty clear that Satoshi later you know
after releasing bitcoin started to
understand this system but in the
beginning there was not like a clear
understanding probably the biggest you
know contentious soft fork in 2009 was
the Satoshi added a one megabyte block
size limit and to reverse a soft fork is
a hard fork and so the sort of block
size hard fork and then there was a very
clever way with segue to make it a soft
work but also sort of increase the block
size in a weird way that the old
software wouldn't recognize I might yeah
I might have to explain a little bit of
segue next week okay so yeah it's it's
sort of a feature in a book right
consensus changes in these systems can
be very difficult on the one hand you
know you want your coins to stay put you
don't want your money to change you want
to be able to just have a bunch of money
and a year later you still have a bunch
of money and that's you know that's what
you want to do on the other hand new
features are cool and you know these are
not ossify you don't want these to be
ossified legacy systems you want this to
be like new cool technology and you go
make all these new cool things and make
it faster and better stronger and the
role of miners is also a big point of
contention
right they seem to have outsized
influence in some ways right you know a
lot of the up here is the mining power
and how that affects things and why
should these miners have outsized
influence you know shouldn't the users
themselves be able to vote but they
can't right if the users could vote
maybe you wouldn't need mining at all to
verify blockchain so there will continue
to be a lot of debate on this stuff
going into the future I hope this helped
explain the general thinking as of
early 2018 but it'll probably change
cool any other questions about this
whole thing if you have a like I don't
know James
helps develop Verte Colline right our
hard forks and softworks difficult and
very clean no you just sort of you're
like hey we're doing a hard work and
yeah so in smaller communities smaller
coins where there's not as many people
involved and people sort over all on the
same page these changes can be made
fairly regularly not a huge deal bitcoin
is very messy Bitcoin everyone hates
each other they're always trolling each
other on the internet and hacking each
other death threats all sorts of stuff
so yeah future forking methods there's
probably new cool ways you can add to
the bottom of that chart some new idea
that maybe works better so stay tuned